hello everyone and welcome to the second
game of the 1970 palma de mallorca
tournament the interest on all
tournaments sorry about the long intro
in my previous video but it is the first
game in the series and you know your
vast knowledge will not increase by
itself so in the first game Bobby was
able to only get a draw here he faces a
former world champion vasily smyslov and
he does have the black pieces so it's
gonna be a very exciting game let's see
how game number two went Smith's table
opens with c4 so the English opening we
have g6 by Bobby Knight to c3 Bishop to
g7 the great snake variation g3 and c5
now they're going for the symmetrical
variation Bishop - G - we have Knight to
c6 b3 e 6 and Bishop to b2 neither G to
e7 and here already
it's it's only move number Seven's
missiles plays nice to a4 it's kind of
breaking the opening principles you're
moving the same piece twice in the
opening word you know you could simply
continue on developing pieces but it
seems like a perfectly logical move
Knight a for forcing a trade of the dark
square bishop so you can see that Bobby
placed all of his pawns on light squares
so it makes sense to get rid of the dark
square bishop and okay Bobby plays a
bunch of capture some b2 Knight capture
some b2 and now Bobby castles we have
III d5 by Fischer C capture some d5
Knight captures some d5 and the Knight
to e2 now and b6 now you can see that
Fischer will develop the lights worship
either via Bishop to d7 or Bishop to a6
and the the pawns on light squares here
on the King side will not be a problem
we have d4 and here Bishop to e6 Bishop
to e6 is a very nice move by Fischer
kind of preventing smell from castling
if he would castle immediately then C
capture Sundy four wins upon each cap
force on the phone but d4 and now Bishop
captures on e2 Queen captures Knight
captures here Fischer wins the pawn and
also you know maintains a better
position here after Bishop to a 6d
captures on c5 was played
but now Fisher of course doesn't
recapture immediately he goes for the
initiative Queen to f6 so a nice pawn
sacrifice but you know he does get a lot
of initiative in return already
attacking the knight on b2 so that
little maneuver Knight to a4 followed by
night bringing the knight back to be to
when the dark square Bishop were
exchanged allows official for this night
nice a pawn sacrifice for the initiative
Knight to c4 and now nice to see three
attacking attacking the Queen we have
Knight captures on c3 but Queen captures
on c3 and now you can't really block
this check if you try and block with the
Queen Queen captures on a1 is coming if
you block with the knight Knight - D -
then you lose the game immediately do
you see how black wins the game try to
try to pause the video you don't have to
like pause it forever a long time it's
not a very difficult tactic but still
for those of you who did pause the video
and were able to do it congratulations
you are an excellent player and for
those who just wanna enjoy the show
nice to e5 is the move that would win
you the game you can even even offer the
rook here an a it doesn't really matter
you can't allow nice to d3 check as you
can see this bishop is slicing all the
way to f1 the knight and D to spin so
you cannot allow an ID three check White
has to block at Bishop before but then
f5 and it's all over you have to decide
what to do with the bishop either you
move the bishop and then rook a to the
8th will win there's no defense against
Knight to f3
whatever white plays Knight to f3 you
have to capture the night Queen captures
and now Queen captures d2 will be
checkmate n even if you don't move after
f5 if you play something like Bishop
captures an a8 then it's pretty much the
same 93 check you have to go in front of
the bishop knife Knight B to check you
lose the Queen and the game so very nice
idea Queen to c2 recheck King to f1 so
now Smith Slav
loses castling privileges and it will be
very hard to develop this rook we have
rook F to d8 attacking Smith's Queen
Queen to c1 offering a queen trade and
now Bishop captures
c4 with Czech pawn captures and now
Queen to d3 check King to g1 and now
rook a to c8 so Fisher doesn't have a
lot here but Smith love is for the time
being playing without his h1 rook C
capture some b6 a capture some b6 and
now Quinta b2 we have Knight to a5 h4
that's really not all that easy to
figure out what to do here with white
pieces you could grab the pawn on d6
then white will grab on c4 doesn't
really do all that much
what's miss love really has to do is
develop this rook somehow there's really
no good way to develop it one way might
be h4 h5 and perhaps bring your rook to
h4 and then somehow develop it but it
will not be easy
this missile does go for h4 we have
Knight captures on c4 attack nice miss
loss Queen Queen to f6 and here Queen to
f5 now now Bob is confident that his
position is so much better that he can
go for a queen trade Queen captures an
f5 we have G captures on f5 and now h5 s
missile still has to develop the rook on
h1 we have rook to d2 Fischer activates
his rook we rook to c2 c1 and now rook
the c5 now the night and c4 can move as
the the Seabrooke is protected rock to
h4 with a double attack on the night and
now comes Knight to e5 rook captures on
c5 b captures on c5 and rock to a4 we
have c4 as of course passed pawns must
be pushed that pawn is already on c4 c3
c to c 1 is coming very soon we have h6
here's miss love threatens rook to e8
check which will of course result in
checkmate after freshman blocks so you
do have to move the King King to f8 and
now comes Luke 2:8 check King to e7 and
now Rock the c8 now you have to it's a
general rule that rooks belong behind
passed pawns your own rocks or your
opponent's works but they belong behind
a spawns
rook captures an 8 - Bishop to f1 with a
double attack on the c4 pawn and now
simply rook to c2 defending King to g2
we have Knight to g4 now threatening the
f2 pawn
and here's myself plays King 2g1 but it
doesn't help him all that much not not
only capturing an f2 was a threat also
Knight captures and III was a threat as
the f2 pony spin so here came to g1 is
played Smith's love is hoping for
Fischer to capture an f2 so maybe he
would capture and c4 but it doesn't help
him all that much rook captures an f2 is
played and now Bishop has to capture you
can't capture with the rook because of
rook captures on f1 that's the problem
King captures Knight captures III check
King moves you lose the rook you're down
two points and the whole piece this
would be completely winning for black I
still have to look to f2 Bishop captures
on c4 was played in our rook to f3 going
after d3 pawn and the g3 pawn king g2
defending now rook captures only three
Fischer is now up two points rook to h8
going after the h7 pawn a Fischer
captures d6 pawn rook captures on h7 and
now Knight back to g4 Bishop to b5 we
have looked to be three attacking the
bishop bishop to c6 and now rook to be
to check King g1 and now Knight to e5 I
see how Fischer is attacking that light
square Bishop Bishop to a8 and now rook
to b8 forcing the bishop all the way to
h1 Bishop to h1 and after a Smith's off
played this Bishop to h1 move he also
resigned the game the game I believe the
game was adjourned here so it was
supposed to be continued the next day
but Smith resigned here without even
waiting for Bobby's response while its
missile resign here well he is down two
points and while you perhaps could hold
this you know to some degree in some
positions he thought that here it would
be pointless to play this position on
against against Bobby here black can
play rook to b3 attack the b3 pawn and
there's really not all that much you can
do here your your Bishop is well it's
not a very active please there you have
to defend the g3 pawn I should play rook
to h3 then you're just gonna have a
lousy Rock on h3 for the entire game you
can defend it with King g2 King f2 if
you're tracking f2 then 94 check is
coming you have to bring the King to g2
anyway so you might as well
put it on g2 immediately and here let's
say 90 g4 white has a terrible bishop on
each one that's really not going
anywhere it's really hard to develop
this rook you could try rock h8 to bring
it back into the game
but now rook to be one now the king will
never be able to leave g2 as he does
have to guard the bishop on h1 if rook
leaves h8 so let's say rook to e8 and
now simply e5 but I can simply push the
e pawn to victory let's say check King
of 6 check again King g7 you tuck away
the King behind the f7 pawn and after we
attack the pawn you can even push efore
you can never capture here because
Knight e3 check will pick up the rook
soldiers there's really nothing to do
here white white is without a move and
black will simply push the e pawn to
victory so after this Bishop to h1 move
is myself thought okay I had enough good
game Bobby so this is game number two
from Palma de Majorca intra zonal
tournament in 1970 I do hope you enjoyed
it here we can check out we can check
out the standings after a tournament so
you can you know remember it ok you did
say that I might have spoiled the result
before actually finishing the series but
as this is an intra zonal tournament you
know you have to win it to qualify for
the candidates well not win it but being
the top six contenders to qualify for
the candidates tournament and since you
all know Bobby Fischer did win the World
Chess Championship I kind of don't think
it's I spoiled the result but ok ok I do
see your point so let's let's not show
it until the end of the series just
anymore so yeah that's that's the game a
brilliant game against miss lob and
really how how he pulled it off after
this like move seven worst missile just
went nice to a4 and it's a perfectly
reasonable decision getting rid of the
dark square bishop as Fischer has all of
his pawns on light squares but how
Fischer uses this for a nice initiative
you know really just just a magnificent
game so I would like to thank Nikolas
credito for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really
she that as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here I think all for
watching and I will see you soon with
game number three from from this
tournament from Bobby's perspective
think'll and all season